second in masters berlin second in the
na challengers grand final always the
bridesmaid never the bride not able to
do much to shock guard swings to do his
finesse but fox gets three
finesse left alone and it happens
the green wall shows its cracks as the
north american representatives fall fns
has been chasing glory for most of his
career cs was basically my entire life
so being able to switch out of it was
difficult for me but as soon as i
switched to valrant i there were no
regrets i didn't like look back and say
like why did i do it but even in a new
game
fns still struggled but is this a divine
comedy for dante's inferno by saya
player
after trying and failing to win
something for so many years
fns didn't have many shots left but fate
gave him one more chance to lead his
team to glory
how are you still doing that too late no
way emphasis
unbelievable scenes
dawn of the life in your hands optic on
the verge and it's all but over it's
overdone optic gaming build their legacy
brick fine brick the green wall of optic
make rager make their own
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to let you know that we've got a
new show coming your way it's called
worth and it's about the greatest
stories in esports that are worth
telling you can check it out on june 2nd
so make sure to please sub to the
channel and turn on notifications so you
don't miss it fns has been around in
esports longer than almost anyone but
despite his years of competing for most
of his career he struggled fns dedicated
nearly a decade of his life to leading
cs go teams to some of the game's
biggest stages and then losing once they
got there every time one of his teams
looked poised to break into the upper
echelon of the global cs scene they
always fell short
it's just one man it is cutler the
in-game leader he can't do anything it
is navi that will face envious tomorrow
in the quarter-finals once again it is
such a sad sad story for clg fans it has
a smoke has whatever he wants for
utility but not much of a chance let's
be honest
they're all gonna peak him now and that
is it liquid we'll move on not only
gonna play in the grand final for a
little bit of cash but they will go to
the offline final close qualifier for
the major fns was usually the first one
on the chopping block when things went
south he helped from team to team for
years and every time it seemed like he
finally had something special everything
would come crashing down on him yet
again by 2020 effiness's career looked
over
his team was literally orgless and as
the kova 19 pandemic hit many north
american teams pulled out of
counter-strike altogether so without any
funding this up-and-coming roster was
basically forced to switch to valorant
in april 2020. fns was hesitant to make
the switch but he realized pretty
quickly that it was a necessary change
cs was basically my entire life so being
able to switch out of it was difficult
for me but as soon as i switched to
valorent i there were no regrets i
didn't like look back and say like why
did i do it now unfortunately for fns
most of his former cs teammates switched
games long before him and were already
part of established valorem teams so
once again he was forced to build a new
team from the ground up
two answers back into 2v3 and the
spike's about to hit the site
outside they have inside its caboose
long range only one to go he's done it
before but not this time crashes gets
the last kill envy wins that second map
13-7 and the series and the champions to
the sky cloud9 invitational is now
possessed and crowned by envy envy
quickly became known as one of the best
valorent rosters in na fns had years of
igl experience and once they picked up
victor and crashies from t1 they seemed
unstoppable but there was one big
problem envy just couldn't win when it
mattered most
only a few seconds left but folks this
could very well be at envy's life in the
tournament on the line here the push
comes through and wardell locks it in
tsm are going to the grand finals of
first strike
right through the smoke shots come
through the spike is sticking he's got
to run over he's got a defeat he's got
to find the time but that is the one
thing and he lacked congratulations to
100 thieves for moving on to the grand
final aaron finds another he's got the
classic in hand he can't find four but
the bucky is there now finesse has to go
huge they had the rifles but it doesn't
matter except win the rematch
you could count on them to go deep at
almost any tournament and you could also
count on them to fall short every time
fns was reliving his cs go career all
over again he sat on the sidelines and
watched as other teams were hailed as
the best in n.a envy tried everything
they shook up their roster ahead of
masters berlin and things looked great
until they didn't and fns was sent home
with yet another loss on his record
crashes could have slipped back towards
ct or sat deeper but they have now three
four on the side for envy and crash is
just watching is one that stopped off
but
has he found that infamous has fallen
yay still said that such victim only for
so long gambit have just butchered envy
envy come on you got to make this happen
crykel he walks through and destroys
envy three back-to-back frags and it
might be four in a second he's on the
chopping block gambit have made it to
12. it's all going to pieces
in the final moments has just shone so
brightly they are blinded by the lights
gambin are the valerian masters
champions
and then at champions it all happened
all over again to take their timings
let's get the first one victor can you
get the trade he can one versus one
victor for envy but it's zeke who pulls
it out of the bag and ascend get the
defuse they're moving to the a site
cruise will try to hold on and he gets
away with three the lockdown will do
absolutely
nothing x10 have the advantage in a 2v1
in the playoffs the stun to the backside
oh they're going to eliminate sushi boy
to start with but patty is still going
strong on the backside down through the
cloud first it comes to bladestorm but
it's not even needed scary closes it out
and sca are going all the way to
playoffs envy season ended in disaster
fns was right back where he started and
the losses were piling up going to 2022
he and his team had a lot to prove
rise looking really good but marv and
yay are both left alive right now and
they're gonna go for this one the cosmic
divide comes in they're gonna try to
force the issue beyond the wall bath
goes in and gets taken down rise take
down optic in this thrilling best of
three here fns and optic got off to a
rough start in 2022 they had a pretty
shaky group stage in stage 1 challengers
and barely clinched a playoff spot after
a performance that shaky it seemed like
fns was once again doomed to repeat
history but then optic went on a tear in
the playoffs as it all falls on to death
the leader for except
nothing doing this time around optic
takedown exit two to one fashion crashes
will close it out there's no way to hang
on and optic have done it they dethrone
the kings and they're one step closer to
representing north america and iceland
now up to net he falls down as well and
soya player is gonna have to try to
clutch at 3v1 he does get those two
kills but that's not enough the envious
of the green wall but unfortunately
despite all their wins
optic fell short in the grand finals yet
again what is this a divine comedy for
dante's inferno by saya player 1v1 with
crowds
and as the green wall crumbles it's five
fresh faces who now stand guard over the
north american region even though they
lost optics playoffs run guaranteed them
a spot in iceland to represent n a as
one of the region's best teams but once
again they weren't the best team from
n.a and their first group stage
opponents immediately reminded them of
that
he's gotten two he needs one more
no shot he sticks it no shot he sticks
in my goodness like a thief in the night
not able to do much to shock dart swings
through his finesse gets three finesse
left alone
and it happens
the green wall shows its cracks as the
north american representatives fall
to zersha from thailand
this wasn't them kind of like playing
against an optic that was crumbling
under the pressure that was what it was
last time they played right that was
that was the kind of makeup of it you
know victor obviously also having
covered at the time then
i mean jess you were saying i mean
there's no excuse no no no no no no
zersha beat optic at champions in
december and now they embarrassed them
at masters that loss put optic on the
verge of elimination they bounced back
by taking them crew in the lower bracket
but with only one spot left in the
playoffs they'd have to beat zersha to
make it but this time things were
different fns had a little trick up his
sleeve for the rematch sushi boys now
let's see if they do hard clear left
because that's gonna be the next problem
they do victor clears out sushi and
around the back inside surfs around and
he knows he's in trouble how does he
find this pick how does he stay alive he
can't because mark just behind him yeah
he's right there and it's a shut down
blink and you're missing you might just
miss this whole game all right setting
pace like this they rinse and repeat and
they're gonna have to be trying to
predict those next adjustments those
adaptations and that's exactly according
no man's land oh victor's just slicing
through them like a hot knife through
butter
tap on the spike
and the desperate hold on towards long
and it's still looking messy oh no way
does it happen like this
heartbreak for sercia
just take it away from them what a
statement game xersha just didn't have
an answer for victor's neon he dominated
the series with a server high
291 acs to catapult optic into the
playoffs even though they lost their
opening match to the same team fns got
his roster into shape for the perfect
moment he refused to lose again
five seconds left they're just trying to
squeeze it out valen the third forum
swings through and finessing to the back
he's so low but he drops down valen he's
finding the fire rate and the swing
again is there fns
what a performance
shuts it down wasn't easy for them not
in the slightest
they are going to be moving forward in
that upper bracket
what an insane comeback
in the next series optic played
perfectly around victor again taking
down the guard as revenge for their loss
back at challengers
optics showed that the neon pick wasn't
just a gimmick although other teams
tried it in the past fns found a way to
perfect it
but he'd need more than just innovation
to win don't forget fns had been here
before
almost on top of the world but not quite
there the only other teams left in the
tournament were favorites to win it all
and optic had a history of choking but
this time
they were ready for a challenge
they are just swinging them down
crashy's desperate to try and do it but
now time has he bought enough time
for the defuse
just going to hold this down as best
they can and
look at that breath
the rx i thought they had the jump on
that i thought they would have had that
on the money but yay's managed to slip
in as well slip the net he's gonna
isolate one yay doing so nicely here
beautiful work from optic to handle that
because that looked good from drx pops
the old
we wait for buzz to try and get closer
here everything in the next moment it's
yay to do it and it's optic the masters
of disaster
after taking down drx optics next
opponent was the brazilian super team
loud since forming back in january loud
hadn't lost a single match they
dominated brazil and they were
dominating in iceland he comes up and
over the site clearing out everything
they know that he's on the back pancata
trying to hold on he'll get one two in
fact
quite working not quite going as far up
as they wanted good pick out of aspes up
against opponents with no shields to
play with here essentially has an
operator to work with and look at him
making it work left right and center
three kills make it four
all these angles opening up for loud and
the kills are going their way it's left
to finesse and he falls as well brazil
have done it they've made history as
they go all the way to the grand finals
this was optics last chance fns knew the
pain of coming so close to victory and
losing but he wasn't about to give up
yet but if fns wanted revenge and a
chance at victory he'd have to face a
truly unstoppable force
zeta division were tearing through the
bracket in iceland they weren't just an
incredible cinderella story against all
odds he beat some of the best teams in
the entire world when i speak of unheard
of i really have to throw back to the
fact that japan as a whole region in
tactical fbs has only ever made it to a
top three top four position before in
rainbow six siege back in 2019 six
invitational there are some serious
gunners in japan and they've done what
is now set history for japan in tactical
fbs but fns wanted his rematch with loud
he wanted to win
and zeta's magical run wasn't going to
stop him no stars for sugar zero to
maybe pull him off the plant
they're just already taking this sugar
just diving in no help from the rest of
his team and
trademark as well that's slow field
brutal to try and push through now to
stun only the one connection a quick
flick though martha's already finding
the value for them alongside it still
left alone crow wants to try and get it
to span through so low but time it's
running out he has to stick it
the circle shrinking mars swings it at
the perfect time once more optics
stomped zeta 3-0 and earned their
rematch against allowed but this time
they weren't going to make the same
mistakes despite coming into the grand
finals at a huge disadvantage due to map
vetoes fns and his coaching staff made
sure that the second time around they
were ready for everything loud through
with them marv he's behind him no he's
gonna just unleash yet find sassy swings
and finds another mob digs deep when
they need it but it's still a 2v2 and
we've seen these have problems
you've got to look towards tt as well
keep that
in the back of your mind who gets this
it's marved they've suddenly got a new
way to defend this crash is just trying
to play the time try and find a little
bit more in here
how are you still doing that too late no
way effortless unbelievable scenes
address the site first fight found for
crashes quick turn didn't note anyone
towards double doors
life in your hands optic on the verge
and it's all but over it's all but done
optic gaming build their legacy brick
[ __ ]
their own
optics swept loud in the grand finals in
large part thanks to fns's shotcalling
after years of falling short of glory he
finally had his first international
title and his teammates did too anything
you want to say to your fans out there
thank you guys so much for supporting us
uh we came in today super confident
ready to win uh thank you guys again for
the support it just means the world to
all of us optic were happy to finally
get their hands on the masters trophy
but for fns this one meant everything
fns grinded for the past decade
searching for his first big win
at 30 years old he came to iceland as
the oldest player at the entire
tournament
and after dealing with ups and downs
through his entire career
he finally had his moment it just feels
good to have this roster get a
championship because it felt
earned you know it felt earned for a
while and it felt like we were grinding
enough and practicing enough to where we
reached a championship level so i'm glad
that he finally won
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
you